POLITICAL ELITE.
THEMES THAT HELP DEFINE THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND IS IN THAT
RACE AND IT'S NOT JUST A
CANDIDATE BUT A LIVING METAPHOR.
GILLIBRAND HAS LIVED A
REMARKABLY FORTUNATE LIFE UNTIL
ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO, SHE WAS A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
NOBODY OUTSIDE THE RURAL
DISTRICT IN UPSTATE NEW YORK AND
NEVER HEARD OF HER.
SHE WAS CONSIDERED AN AVERAGE
MEMBER OF CONGRESS, MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT BELOW AVERAGE.
ONE DAY HILLARY CLINTON DECIDED
TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT AND
GILLIBRAND HIT PAY DIRT.
SHE WAS PLUCKED FROM OBSCURITY
AND HANDED ONE OF THE SAFEST
SENATE SEATS IN AMERICA.
OVERNIGHT, GILLIBRAND BECAME A
NATIONAL FIGURE WITHOUT EVEN
HAVING TO WIN AN ELECTION.
AMAZING.
IT WAS THE POLITICAL EQUIVALENT
OF INHERITING A BILLION DOLLARS.
MAYBE NOT SURPRISINGLY,
GILLIBRAND'S VIEWS CHANGED
ACCORDINGLY.
SHE SOON ADOPTED THE POLITICS OF
THE TRUST FUND LEFT.
BEFORE LONG, THERE WASN'T A
FASHIONABLE OPINION SHE DIDN'T
HAVE ON ANY TOPIC, GUNS,
ABORTION, IMMIGRATION, YOU NAME
IT.
AS HER FRIENDS IN ASPEN AND
MARTHA'S VINEYARD BECAME MORE
DECADENT AND MORE CONTEMPTUOUS
OF THE COUNTRY AROUND THEM,
SORTED KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND.
BY THIS PAST WEEKEND WHEN SHE
APPEARED ON "FACE THE NATION,"
GILLIBRAND WAS ARGUING AGAINST
CONTINUING TO OPERATE THE
UNITED STATES AS A SOVEREIGN
COUNTRY.
LET EVERYONE IN, SHE DEMANDED,
DETAINING ANYONE IS IMMORAL.
WATCH.
>> YOU OPPOSE EVEN WITH THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION DID IN
TERMS OF KEEPING FAMILIES
TOGETHER OR KEEPING THEM
TOGETHER FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME IN DETENTION?
>> AS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, I WOULDN'T USE
THE DETENTION SYSTEM AT ALL.
>> HOMELAND SECURITY IS SAYING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ARE CROSSING THE BORDER AND THEY
NEED TO GO SOMEWHERE BEFORE
THERE ARE SEVEN CLAIMS ARE
HEARD.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO WITH THEM?
>> THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
INCARCERATED.
IF THEY ARE GIVEN A LAWYER AND
GIVEN A PROCESS, THEY WILL
FOLLOW IT.
>> Tucker: HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE OVER TIME.
WHERE WILL ALL THOSE PEOPLE GO?
THEY WON'T GO TO KIRSTEN
GILLIBRAND'S NEIGHBORHOOD
OBVIOUSLY.
THEY ARE NOT HEADED TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD OR ASPEN OR
SOUTHHAMPTON OBVIOUSLY BUT THEY
ARE GOING TO DYING INDUSTRIAL
CITIES GILLIBRAND COULD       BL
CITIES GILLIBRAND COULD       BE
CITIES GILLIBRAND COULD       BS
CITIES GILLIBRAND COULD       BC
CITIES GILLIBRAND COULD       BU
CITIES GILLIBRAND COULD       BD
USE MORE DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
>> THE STATE OF NEW YORK TAKES
REFUGEE FAMILIES INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WE WOULD BE DELIGHTED TO TAKE
REFUGEE FAMILIES INTO CITIES
LIKE BUFFALO AND SYRACUSE AND
ROCHESTER AND ALBANY.
>> Tucker: THINK FOR A MINUTE
ABOUT WHAT GILLIBRAND IS SAYING.
SHE IS ARGUING ANYBODY FROM
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD MUST BE
ALLOWED INTO THE UNITED STATES,
ORDERED A BUBBLY FINANCE LAWYER,
GIVEN A FREE PLACE TO LIVE ALONG
WITH THREE HEALTH CARE AND
SCHOOLS, ALL OF WHICH YOU
PAY FOR, AND ALLOWED TO STAY
INDEFINITELY UNLESS THEY LOSE A
COURT CASE THAT BY THE WAY THEY
WILL DEFINITELY SHOW UP FOR.
THAT'S HER CORE ASSUMPTION.
THE PEOPLE HAVE DEMONSTRATED
CONTEMPT FOR OUR LOSS WILL
ARRIVE IN COURT WHEN
ASKED.
GILLIBRAND TRUST THEM TO DO THAT
AND WHY WOULDN'T SHE?
THAT'S THE WHOLE IMMIGRATION
ARGUMENT SHE'S MAKING, WHICH IS
UNLIKE YOU, REGULAR AMERICANS
WHO ARE LAZY AND STUPID AND NOT
WORTH HELPING, IMMIGRANTS ARE
BASICALLY PERFECT.
THEY ARE SMARTER, MORE
INDUSTRIOUS, MORE CREATIVE THAN
YOU OR ANY OF YOUR NEIGHBORS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY BELIEVE.
THE FACTS SUGGEST MORE COMP
GATED PICTURE.
RECENTLY I.C.E. LAUNCHED A PILOT
PROGRAM TO CONDUCT DNA TESTS OF
ADULT AND CHILDREN ARRIVING AT
EL PASO AND McALLEN, TEXAS.
WHEN THEY CHECKED, THEY FOUND
NEARLY A THIRD OF THE KIDS WERE
NOT RELATED TO THE ADULTS THEY
WERE WITH.
IT WAS FRAUD ON A MASSIVE SCALE.
IT ALSO REVEALED SOMETHING FAR
DARKER.
REVEALS OUR DELIBERATE FAILURE
TO PROTECT OUR BORDERS HAS MADE
OUR OWN GOVERNMENT PARTY TO THAT
TRAFFICKING OF CHILDREN.
IT WOULD BE HARD OVERALL TO
DESIGN AN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM
THAT'S WORSE FOR OUR COUNTRY.
BUT DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE.
TO A PARTY TOTALLY CONTROLLED BY
IDENTITY POLITICS, EVERYTHING IS
ABOUT RACE OR GENDER OR
SEXUALITY.
NOTHING ELSE MATTERS, INCLUDING
REALITY.
WATCH CONGRESSWOMAN MAXINE
WATERS EXPLAIN.
>> SOME OF THAT IS VERY RACIST.
IT'S NOT KEEPING WITH WHAT THIS
COUNTRY SUPPOSED TO BE ALL
ABOUT.
>> WHAT EXACTLY IS, SO OUR
VIEWERS KNOW?
>> THIS BUSINESS BUT YOU MUST
SPEAK ENGLISH.
WERE GOING TO GIVE YOU POINTS TO
WE DON'T WANT POOR PEOPLE.
WE ONLY WANT THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE EARNING SUBSTANTIAL WAGES
ALREADY.
I THINK SOME OF THOSE POLICIES
ARE RACIST.
>> Tucker: IMAGINE THE CNN
ANCHOR ASKING OF MAXINE WATERS,
JUST TO BE SPECIFIC, WHAT IS
RACIST?
EVERYTHING, OF COURSE.
IN THIS CASE, SHE AND VIRTUALLY
EVERYONE ELSE IN OUR PARTY IS
ARGUING THAT AMERICANS HAVE NO
RIGHT TO WANT IMMIGRANTS WHO
SPEAK ENGLISH.
AMERICANS HAVE NO RIGHT TO WANT
IMMIGRANTS WITH JOB SKILLS.
NANCY PELOSI EXPLAINED THAT LAST
WEEK.
AMERICANS HAVE NO RIGHT TO
DECIDE HOW MANY IMMIGRANTS
COMING ARE OR HOW LONG THEY
STAY, AND YET AS KAMALA HARRIS
AND JOE BIDEN AND OTHERS HAVE
JUST TOLD US, AMERICANS ARE
REQUIRED TO PAY FOR FREE
HEALTH CARE FOR EVERYONE WHO
COMES ALONG WITH HOUSING AND
EDUCATION AND LOTS OF OTHERS.
GOT THAT?
YOU CAN SEE WHERE ALL THIS IS
HEADING AND FAST.
IN FRANCE, THEY ARE NEARLY
THERE.
THIS WAS THE SCENE AT CHARLES DE
GAULLE, THE COUNTRY'S BIGGEST
AIRPORT, YESTERDAY, HUNDREDS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FROM AFRICA
TOOK OVER TERMINAL TO MAKE
POLITICAL DEMANDS.
>> [CHANTING]
>> Tucker: AT ONE POINT, THE
LEADER OF THE DEMONSTRATION
CHANTED THIS INTO ALLOWED
SKIPPER "FRANCE DOES NOT BELONG
TO THE FRENCH.
EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT TO BE
HERE."
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT.
AMERICA FOR AMERICANS?
THAT'S RACIST.
YOU DON'T DESERVE YOUR OWN
COUNTRY.
GILLIBRAND AND HER FRIENDS ON
THE LEFT, AMERICA IS NOT A
NATION.
IT'S A PINATA FILLED WITH 200
YEARS OF TREASURE.
GET SOME BEFORE IT'S GONE.
THAT'S WHAT GILLIBRAND IS
PROMISING THE WORLD.